que las deportaciones no sean una
prioridad es un cambio que llega desde
el primer día de la administración va ir
en el nuevo presidente apuesta por
reforzar el programa daca que blinda a
cientos de miles de migrantes que
llegaron a la unión americana cuando
eran niños es un plan que tiene en la
mira del presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador que ha pedido a su
homólogo job aid en una reforma
migratoria esto en medio del fenómeno de
las caravanas que llegan desde
centroamérica ya el nuevo departamento
de seguridad nacional anunció una
moratoria de 100 días en algunas
deportaciones para asegurar una
aplicación efectiva de estas medidas si
creemos que este va a ser el año de la
reforma migratoria
nosotros estamos sacando hoy en día una
carta abierta al presidente by the app
porque estamos pidiéndole que cumpla la
promesa de esta reforma migratoria la
política migratoria de washington es una
preocupación general en américa latina
pero cada país tiene sus propios
intereses en colombia el gobierno había
contado con el apoyo del ex presidente
de la cndh trump para retomar su
política de las aspersiones con
glifosato para hacer frente a unas
cifras récord de cultivos de hoja de
coca en brasil
jair bolsonaro se queda sin un aliado
importante con la salida de trump
mientras tanto el presidente de
venezuela nicolás maduro espera que haya
un punto de inflexión yo llamo para que
el nuevo gobierno de eeuu
supere la demonización que han hecho de
la revolución bolivariana del comandante
chávez de nicolás maduro
y pase la página
otro aspecto clave en las relaciones con
américa latina es la economía china es
hoy en día el primer socio comercial de
brasil chile perú uruguay argentina el
gigante asiático además ha aprovechado
la pandemia para estrechar sus lazos con
la región con la venta de suministros
como los ventiladores y las mascarillas